i feel like we are so blessed to have
the best support system and the best
family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
kanye west is feeling refreshed after
spending
a little quality time with his support
system
his wife kim kardashian and therefore
kiddos
at the end of the day life is about
being happy an eyewitness tells e.t
that the 43 year old rapper and his fam
arrived in miami around 11
15 a.m on sunday after a little r
r in the dominican republic kim seemed
fine and not worried at all she had the
kids close by her
kanye didn't seem worried either he
walked with his head up
the whole time i'm just extremely happy
can you tell by my face
another source tells et that kanye is in
a great place right now
adding that he's feeling creatively
inspired and really enjoying his family
time
and apparently the family fun isn't over
yet
tmz reports that the west are going
yes west to go glamping
glamping it's like camping except way
more glam
it's been so much fun to be on this
journey
with someone that just brings you on
this like whirlwind
of a life that i never dreamed that i
would have so
it's been a lot of fun the family's
getaway comes after
kim and kanye's emotional reunion at
their ranch in wyoming last month
i mean we have different views sometimes
but
that's my husband you know following
that storm of since-deleted tweets kanye
posted about his wife and her mom kris
jenner
but i always believe and trust in him
that he will
always eventually explain himself and
yay's first presidential rally in south
carolina where he revealed he and kim
talked about having an abortion when she
was pregnant with their first child
north
so even if my wife were to divorce me
after this speech
she brought north into the world even
when i didn't want to
she stood up and she protected that
child a source told et at the time
quote the couple knows they need quality
time with their kids
and no other outside voices are people
kim knows that kanye being with his
family
will be good for him i've seen him go
through
a lot but i always know his heart